duh let me throw it out to you first
because there's going to be a lot going
on in Washington today a lot of
discussions not just in the White House
about what assistance they can give to
France in this industry but also in
congressional leadership and the
discussions around what the president
has or hasn't done around Islamic state
yeah I think you'll look at Congress
talking about what the president should
do and what the president has been doing
but in a way of how we can best help the
French people you'll see no divide
between Republicans or between
Republicans and Democrats will be
unified because this is just an awful
attack and it's very clear that we'll
all move together forward for France
just as France stood behind us after the
911 attacks what usually happens at this
at this point um you've been through
many crises Doug I know in your time in
DC walk me through the steps when a
crisis like this like this hits what
goes on on the hill the first thing is
you gather the facts you want to know
what happened when it happened and then
how it happened so we're already seeing
from the news reports exactly what
happened we're learning more every
minute that's why you're seeing members
of Congress and leadership starting to
talk about certainly we stand with
France these attacks are appalling but
that's the preliminary we still want to
know more we still want to find out
exactly what happened so we can figure
out how to prevent these things in the
future but also demonstrating the whole
time that we stand with France and we
stand with the leadership of France
we've seen strong leadership already
with President oland already on the
scene and that's important for the
French press French president to show
that leadership we're absolutely no
divine today no by part no partisanship
at all and you know this is amazing i'm
just watching the twitter feed from from
Lamanna this morning they have an email
from he's a he's a a researcher he's
very close to the the editorial staff of
of Charlie Hebdo Jean y of Camus he
wrote some all of the men I know were
dead this is something that we have
never seen in the history of our country
an organ of the press is methodically
decimated after
a military attack this is really this is
there have been attacks have been fire
bombings on Charlie Hebdo but this is
unprecedented this you know we have seen
already in the last five years arise in
in far-right parties it's actually a
possible to even call them far-right
parties anymore because they're becoming
increasingly mainstream a play a party
like the front nastya knowledge in the
90s you know what could command possibly
ten percent of the vote is is now
climbing upwards and we're seeing that
across Europe but particularly in in
France cast unseen I know this is not
the heart of the research that you do
but one of the things that's interesting
to me is watching these parties they're
tied into anti-eu sentiment but also
anti-immigration sentiment these are two
things in Europe that have been twinned
for the last decade right whether a
couple things probably two separate one
is there's a sense in the part of some
who are struggling of grievance partly
because of difficult economic
circumstances partly because of
persistence sense of subordination in
some way or another and then that's a
problem and it needs to get a target for
people who are suffering in that way and
the target may be a political target
that is immigration the other issue I
think to get a focus on in this
relationship to terrorist acts remains
to be determined but is if like-minded
people who do have an acute sense of
grievance or outraged are talking to one
another then they can hear each other up
towards great extremism and in the in
the terrible case literal violence
that's fascinating you know this is
we're going to bring this up on on the
screen actually we're looking at the
growth in far-right political parties
all over Europe you bring that up we're
talking about you know serezha and
podemos okay but we can take a look at
it in a second but one of the things I
spoke you know last year to Katherine
devries she's a scholar at Oxford and
she calls these parties entrepreneurial
parties which is that these grievances
that you're talking about they've been
sitting around waiting for somebody to
seize on politically yes well there's
there's an idea actually of polarization
entrepreneurs they're called and these
are people who try to foam
polarization by focusing on a set of
people identifiable along ethnic or
other lives maybe even sociological
lines who have a grievance who should be
polarizing themselves meaning getting
more extreme more politically engaged
more outraged creating something new and
of course civil rights movement
sometimes of the best and most honorable
kinds have been created by polarization
entrepreneurs as they're called so it
can be a well functioning part of a
democracy very important the danger is
when it's based on falsehood when it's
based on kind of hatred when the
political innovations that are sought
aren't helping it yet and you can't
discount what is going on in the French
economy and how that foment some of that
some of that discontent with youth
unemployment in the double digits how
that can lead to some of the
affiliations with the extremist views